vous avez vu l'ordre de mission il nous
envoie pour la dernière fois sur le
terrain et ensuite on rentre à la maison
pour nous c'est fini on est des marines
covax où ils sont tous
[Musique]
passés ce n'est pas évidence ce que vous
traversez ce qu'il faut faire avant
toute chose c'est vous aider à
guérir à quoi je ser et qu'est-ce que je
peux
apporter vous avez déjà pêché pêché je
pense que ça pourrait vous aider Z
là vous êtes avec Fletcher quelle
excellente idée c'est long et fastidieux
ça demande beaucoup d'entraînement
repère le
[Musique]
terrain donc si tu veux tourner les
talents tu veux pas teop
tenir en tout cas tu t' investis
beaucoup ouais je
kiffe et tu penses quoi de ceci j'aime
bien ça son charme ça
va déjà ressenti ça j'ai perdu mon
fiancé cétait qui le jeune là encore un
vtér qui porte tout le malheur du monde
alors vous devriez vous entendre souvent
tu me dis qu'avoir survécu est une forme
de punition et me voilà au milieu de la
rivière et en sentant l'eau couler
autour de moi je sentais qu'elle
emportit avec elle
fr tu sais il regarde pas la télé il
écoute plus de musique pêch c'est tout
ce qu'il a dans la
vie ça passe avec le temps ou non
non cet endroit ça c'est ce qui me
convient le mieux tu viensapendre la
plus importante de toutes les leçons
l'humilité quand je pêchais je pensais
plus à ce qui arriv toi faire la guerre
et as
survécu vousz péché allez-y avec
quelqu'un le temps est venu de découvrir
ce qui va te donner envie de vivre dans
libre d'une vie de soldat l'armée la
guerre ce n'est qu'un
chapitre ce n'est pas non plus toute l'h
histoire
de bon ben si on allait pêcher
maintenant hein
wou